[Music]
okay thank you very much for joining us
the structure of this panel is going to
be fairly straightforward we're going to
have statements from each of the
speakers within five minutes or less and
if I've moderated you before you know
that I keep times then we're going to
start with three questions just to
really get into the practical aspects of
what we can and what we should do
and if there is time hopefully we'll
have questions from the audience so
Cyrus would you like to begin
okay you know we're statement to stop we
gather and put one together and maybe
explain of the work that I'm doing in
degree with the UEA I'm minister and
possibly what's between global
governance of AI one table that we
started convening last year we have a
look at least we have approximately 20%
up to this audience are being there so
we have a strong focus on on on the a
safety so these front table is being
gathered at the world government summit
which is happening every year in Dubai
and as its name says you know it's about
convening and discussing stories around
technology and others that will have an
impact on society and how will
government link with that so since we
have a minister of the ISO 4 year now
and it's also bidding this this summit
he has this fantastic convening power to
bring a really truly multi-stakeholder
approach with people from the civil
society from the scientific community
but also from governments international
organization and others to gather and
discuss this so that's one of the
question that you you're gonna ask too
but I'm getting it up right
it's basically what we have in the UAE
is truly a unique geo strategic location
we extremely friendly we with the u.s.
we extremely friendly with China so
obviously this is these are the tools
with AI superpowers that we so this on
its own isn't
but on top of this we're friendly with
Russia we're friendly with India we're
friendly with Europe so so we have this
unique neutral platform where we can
have a true global conversation
discussing about governance of the iron
impact of the iron society part of this
discussion and that's what we're doing
right now we you know with many of you
are present in this room is bring the
dialogue on on the on hei and the impact
slightly and starting thinking about the
eye safety issues okay thank you I'm
gonna suggest that we use the Cold War
as a role model not as like a general
rule but just for about five minutes I
mean it should stop being a role model
for us but there's several things that
we can learn from the competition
between the United States and the Soviet
Union which was possible much more
hostile than any relationship right now
between AI powers and yet was still able
to support risk producing cooperation
over decades the first form of
cooperation that was useful was informal
engagement of the sort organized by the
Pugwash conferences and very much in the
spirit of this conference was an effort
to bring together international
technologists scientists technocrats in
order to develop lines of communication
that later ended up being quite
important for back panel discussions
during crises so doing more of this sort
of work and possibly similar conferences
that seek to focus on the policy
communities in their respective
countries and are known as for crack 1.5
discussions which you invite government
advisers as participants but they don't
play any formal role plus if it's run by
government there won't be any free food
so that's another advantage of not
having governments run the conferences a
second form of cooperation that was
important during the Cold War were low
stakes technical collaborations
one example is apollo-soyuz in which you
had technologists from the US and the
Soviet Union collaborating on a
constructive project that
didn't involve anyone trying to kill
each other and that was good both as a
confidence-building measure and and also
to help build this connective tissue
between the two communities a third
example of cooperation where high stakes
technical collaborations
one of which was the development of
locks that secure nuclear weapons
against unauthorized use and one example
where the AI community on that might be
an international collaboration to pursue
AI safety research or possibly AI
security research may be one in whose
goals have short term deliverables
something which is concrete and can show
the benefits that sort of cooperation
another example of cooperation would be
agreements to submit oneself to certain
kinds of monitoring for
confidence-building one example during
the Cold War were open skies agreements
in which countries would submit
themselves to aerial reconnaissance so
that we wouldn't become too anxious
about what the other side was building
or arming itself with in the context of
AI as miles and others have talked about
computing does look to be one bottleneck
and semiconductor manufacturing is
fairly centralized that's something that
actually is amenable some level of
monitoring so it might be interesting to
explore what a international agreement
to monitor at least that sort of general
volume of production for semiconductors
would look like the last form of
cooperation I think the most difficult
are arms limitations treaties and we
have many examples of of three DS which
sought to either ban or limit categories
of certain destructive technologies in
the context of AI one that I think could
be an opportunity in the near term is
for the next 40 G arms limitation treaty
to include some ban on the use of
autonomy with a nuclear commanding
control so with that I'll end and say we
should no longer use the Cold War as a
role model
great Thank You Charlotte yeah so I'm
gonna do a mixture between what we just
heard I'm gonna kind of recap what I
look at I'm also going to bring out
through questions that I think are
interesting so my main focus is AI
policy in the European Union why the
European Union well because the European
Union was initially founded as the
European Coal and Steel Community so
Germany and France couldn't go to war
anymore to have shared resources that
would not make it
ethically unthinkable but also
practically unthinkable that these
countries Padres and Europe would be
dipped into World War 3 so I'm not
suggesting that we should all end up in
a global single market and we need to
have shared judicial or legislative
branches or executive branches but I
think it might be worthwhile thinking
about what could be a thing that if all
actors collaborate on it would make it
impossible for one of them to break away
and actually start racing again by
themselves so that's point one point two
is what is the European Union doing
right now well it's actually surprising
still somewhat functional after this
very inception point it is currently
looking at corporation for artificial
intelligence so exactly the type of
topic we are discussing here they have
signed on by day I mean all the 28
member states plus Norway have signed an
agreement to cooperate on artificial
intelligence that is for financial means
that is for ethical and socio economical
reasons so in terms of the labor market
displacement in terms of how do we
educate the next generation how do we
upskill the workers that we already have
and there's also in terms of what common
vision and ball do we want to have which
has been more specified recently in a
plan for coordinated action on AI by the
European Commission and I assume I'll
get the chance later on to speak a bit
more in depth about this but the
Europeans measure
is basically to have ethical AI and
trustworthy AI and I will explain later
on why I think that is a bit more than
just a nice cover up term for not doing
anything else and how this can actually
eventually translate into a mechanism
for governance that doesn't necessarily
require all actors to agree on the same
thing okay okay I think before I go on
to talk about my advice and
recommendations I want to actually I
have a question on the question that's
being raised to us and then we're
talking about the race but I was
thinking what race if we're talking
about you know the AGI race I mean the
whole research project are so stupid
what do you mean no one agrees on the
actual path to AGI so for me it's at the
best this race is a bit Silla it's a
demon lighted cave we don't know what
the finishing line is we don't know what
the shortest distance is and then so in
a way it's fortunately fine what the
race is all about if you don't if you
can't define that and then how can you
talk about you know how to coordinate
between the different you know
stakeholders and stuff so so that's my
question on the questions that opposed
to us but I think you know perhaps you
know this community can help but some of
the idea mistakes about about this race
I don't I'm also helping in some of
their speakers there earlier so before I
talk about the recommendations I want to
get and you know take another I don't
say one step back I want to take two
steps back I think you know I wanted to
talk about my understanding of the comp
the conflicts in clash between US and
China I think essentially what we're
seeing right now it's not just merely
trade disputes and it's really sort of a
civilization or culture clash so let me
use on a metaphor so they will allow us
to understand better what US and China
is all about it's let's say you if
imagine it's an oil painting you have a
multiple layers of paint so at the top
layer paint it's essentially US and
China are speaking the same
we're talking about you know economic
terms and national interest competition
efficiency materialism consumer
consumerism okay
capitalism that's throughout the same
language that in the past four decades
that both US and China have been talking
about so we understand each other but
that's the only the top layer if you go
to the bottom layer the grounding color
of the oil painting to civilizations are
very different so if you look at the UH
the grounding color let's say if you
look at the the US I'm you know I
apologize that I'm sort of resorting to
the oversimplification yeah it's much of
a monotheistic culture individual
individualistic and then a lot of the
emphasis on zero-sum competition and
then then actually when it comes to more
for intellectual let's say purity and
the pursuit there's the you know focus
on logical purity okay so if you look at
the China side the Chinese culture first
of all we're not religious but we're but
we are spiritual okay there's a
difference in here and there's a whole
commitment to this way of Dao and then
some of the the Chinese colleagues
talked about the the unity of of the the
haven't Yin and then and then in humans
a lot of those kind of a spiritual
concept and then we don't we don't have
a modern monotheistic culture and then
also the de Chinese concept focus a lot
more on inclusiveness and a hominid okay
and then and then also the concept that
we have towards human beings it's a
relational be okay that kind of concept
it's not an individualistic and then we
are we pay a lot of attention to the
context driven context driven content
you know contextual driven decision
making and thinking process and then of
course related to that family based
decision making so in the u.s. thinking
the best way is my way the Chinese
thinking we're actually looking for the
most appropriate way there's no such
thing as the best thing
there's only most appropriate depending
on the context and circumstances okay so
so that's why I want to highlight the
different way
of approaching things and thinking that
does inform all the geopolitical tension
as well as the the approach to our AI
developments and the effects engine so I
just want to raise you know the example
let's say the concept of privacy and
then you know privacy in the Western
contact might be very different
a differently understood in the China
contact if you look at the broad
spectrum this that is individual this
that is a social good or now associate
social stability or you know the and
then on this broad spectrum China's
approach to privacy spa problem probably
much more towards the social good side
and then much less on the
individualistic side so so that's why
it's I personally find it very hard to
describe general principles AI
principles without understanding how
they're gonna Inc applied in the
contacts so I just wanted to make use
that as an example so but in terms of
the recommendations some advice I have
we should probably just do that within
the questions just so that but really
quickly I just want to say this is a
great forum for that kind of a
discussion but I do hope we should act
just bring out more
value-based civilizational kind of or
cultural kind of dialogue because I want
to go to the bottom because that's the
thing that means forms everything that
we were discussing about and then
secondly is about the global project
actually Shaun was talking about as well
rather than receiving a big very sort of
berm
you know abstract concept I was thinking
about it was one thing which is less
sensitive is care robots or elderly care
that's a global issue and then so forth
but in a way we should actually
cooperate in the most specific context
is then we can resolve all the privacy
issues and then safety issue and
security issue with us with respect to
one specific product and then we will
see how different that auto you know
understanding will be brought to play so
anyway that's it just a quick note I did
a lot of work on care robots and I could
not agree with us
but we'll get to that later okay
first questions from the panelists from
your point of view what is the most
pressing problem and the most promising
opportunity with regards to
international collaboration whoever
wants to start the dred so you asked
both three I asked her no I asked for a
one pressing problem and one promising
opportunity okay let's keep it simple
the most pressing problem is the most
obvious problem why would people want to
collaborate what are the incentives to
cooperate if you think that you can do
it by yourself so like I think again
very obvious but that seems to be that
is the pressing problem now how can you
change that I think that's what we're
all here to discuss and figure out one
immediate death one immediate step I
think that harks back at what I said
before about the European Union focusing
on ethics is so to embed what I say in
the broader pictures the European Union
is currently working on guidelines for
the ethical development of AI so in
these guidelines that are open to input
which someone mentioned on Friday you
have a statement that the European group
on artificial intelligence the expert
group wishes that ethical AI should be
trustworthy human centric robust and
secure which are all quite exciting
statements I assume for everyone here in
this audience now the question is how
does that translate into something
larger so the idea behind this is that
these guidelines will probably be used
by the European Union in order to find
partners in an international context
that agree on these types of values so
everything the European Union does is
based on the Charter fundamental rights
so AI as well is going to be based it
needs to adhere to the Charter
fundamental rights basic
so which other countries on the globe
agree with these types of values and you
could go further beyond taking that as a
rather straightforward and easily
achievable basis of cooperation agreeing
on ethical principles because you don't
want each cut each country to come up
with their own ethical principles that
are kind of the same but kind of
slightly different and then you have
duplication efforts within countries and
by different groups and across the globe
you could say well maybe we can come
together on this and this being the
ethics guidelines or an ethical charge
or ethical principles but also trickle
down further in what I imagine this is
just an assumption so take that with a
pinch of salt into certification
standardization processes so once we
agree on how do we want AI to be
developed and deployed there are already
organizations like the item four in the
AIA so looking at AI standardization and
certification particular the ILO has a
working group on trustworthy AI so I
assume that in all of this diversity
there will be someone who looks at
different countries or groups statements
and says well actually all of this makes
sense let's consider writing standards
or safety certificates around this and
to me that then in and of itself so
standardization certification which has
also popped up in a lot of different
policy papers across the globe that
x-country wishes to develop AI seals of
quality for example that then in itself
is a kind of indirect way of governing
the broader AI development and
deployment to me at the very least it's
not a complete solution it can go
towards preventing certain small
shortcomings that we already see right
now in an indirect manner okay in the
interest of time and the interest of
coffee if no one wants to take a stab at
the first question we can move on to the
second which is if you could change one
misconception in emerging AI AGI
governance structures what would that be
and I think you alluded to that so we
would
go ahead actually better with the cold
war analogy you really scared me and
then then also in early panel talk about
this fixed I again I think we are using
way too much so the legacy framework and
the legacy concepts to think about the
governance and principles and governance
structure for for AGI or for the future
I think we really need to change our
minds
mindset and we really need to focus on
you know all inclusiveness that's not to
forget that we're talking about HDI
we're talking about a potential exists
initial risk for the humans but also
potentially you know a good relationship
between humans and the machines in
future so so in other words this the
issues of that scale it does not you
know we can't use the past experience I
mean we can use very little past
experience so we really need to think
about something new and then so I would
I would you know think that we would
much prefer this kind of more of a moral
persuasion and then more you know that's
why value based the discussion and then
come up with something more inclusive
and then really want to pitch at the
level for the global narratives that it
is a global issue it is initially faced
by the entire humanity it's not just us
wings and the China loses and vice versa
so that's like the one huge
misconception which we should have we
should really correct this otherwise I
just feel this kind of a confrontational
stuff and by the way guys they learn how
we humans treat each other and how we
treat our machines so we better this is
the time to reflect on ourselves so
let's let's be really you know don't
confrontation don't be confrontational
don't use thick with each other and then
don't do that towards AGI is what
they're gonna learn right so interesting
so you commented about learning from the
Cold War and I wonder how would you
translate that into one misconception
that you think you could change or you
should change in the race dynamic
yeah so I think first I mean so the Cold
War is sort of about as bad and hostile
a competition as there is so the that we
were able to succeed
in building forms of risk-reducing
cooperation during that period suggest
that we should be at least as ambitious
as our counterparts or during the Cold
War I think one misconception is that
right now people at least in the US
policy community really are not cracking
AGI as a topic they're just they're not
enamored with this topic so you in
trying to find ways of engaging with US
policy community at least and maybe
others could talk about other countries
policy communities
I wouldn't frame this in terms of AGI I
mean I think I could have unintended
consequences anyway but I would cream it
in in terms of other things that are
more concrete and accessible
you know like nearer term AI security
issues that may overlap with some of the
longer term AGI safety issues that I
think is a framing that's much more
likely to capture the interest and
support of policymakers in ways that are
constructive and not distracted just one
thing also that Yan was mentioning a
years back AGI is more and more accepted
in in the global discourse now you find
it more in that you know also in public
policy although it's not I haven't seen
it really in any of the AI strategy
documents they've in rule written by
various government so one thing to do is
might be also to educate parents and
policymakers about that we're talking
about guidelines on policy makers so
that's something we could include there
also so it's also educating them on the
notion of value alignments and the why
it's important there so that's something
I would that bring AGI out into the
world
whispering Charlotte yeah I want to kind
of get off of your points um this might
be slightly controversial I'm not sure
I'm gonna say it anyway um I think when
we discuss governance of AI and
collaboration and cooperation we need to
be very certain and quite honest with
our
selves do we mean cooperation between
the nations we think right now are
racing and winning the race
so China in America basically or do we
mean global corporation or do we mean
cooperation between all the large
nations so Canada Australia that
European Union China Japan etc etc etc
because the mechanisms are going to be
drastically different that we need to
employ in order to achieve cooperation
between two countries five countries the
entire globe so I just invite people to
like actually think my kind of
disentangle what we mean when we discuss
cooperation for artificial intelligence
I mean I mean the reason I use your
spanner is pretty easy that's what the
key robust project I'm thinking about
I'm sorry that would be that's a global
institute not just China has it
Japan has it and then you know Western
country all have it right so the aging
population so so I thought that would
there will be in you know kind of a less
sensitive project for but but I'll be
great Global part to be honest so that's
my we may be education we have a very
short time to take audience questions so
quick no statements actual questions
[Laughter]
fourteen standards working groups we've
had them for three years they're open to
anyone to join it's focused on things
like facial recognition multiple things
on personal data and standards are a
form of soft governance they're a way to
build consensus before you get the legal
place so anyone's welcome to join those
I wouldn't ask about China a lot of
feedback we've beginning on our paper we
did three draft the second draft a lot
of people said wow this is Western and
what was great is Shannon valor if no
one's read the book technology and the
virtues I think it's one of the most
important books to read in the space
today at least in terms of short term AI
and what she talks about is that
utilitarianism because you said this and
in your pudding comment utilitarianism
is really about engineers
let's build the elevator so it doesn't
crash and that's kind of important
then deontological stuff is what you're
saying and here a lot of things the
philosophers in the room are not one but
I can hear them on my voice dang we say
things like let's do the right thing
let's do the good thing that means
nothing in a room of philosophers
because you have to say what does right
mean for who virtue ethics as Shannon
describes brilliantly in her book is
this sort of way of staying we actually
have to find those things not care robot
but those things were when we agree on
them together in unison then the good is
actually a unison thing also in the east
virtue ethics seems to be something
through Confucianism this is the
statement does all that make sense
by the way I can't speak on behalf
country speak on behalf of myself so I
would say a lot of it does make sense
but I don't know how that's gonna be
applied in fact I've been thinking hard
about the ethical framework for
regulating up or regulating humans and
machines you know future references I
was thinking about something like a
compassion ethics and so the compassion
ethics is you know in a way that there's
so much we can draw from our from our
tradition and the Chinese and
Confucianism and then you know and then
and also its peak about people or agents
in the power relationship when you say
that compassion you know you have
parents towards children you have you
know people in a power position towards
their weaker ones and they saw those
rich resources in Chinese philosophy
about how that relation should be
regulated what's the people the people
in power position the kind of
obligations you have towards the weaker
ones and then of course you know so I
think that would be very useful
framework at this point I mean we could
use that framework at this point humans
still ruin in the world appears to be
anyway and then you know we use that
framework you know to see it regularly
how we treat the animals and the weaker
beings hopefully in the future
AG eyes will learn from from this and
then if they become more cognitively or
all this level they're more powerful now
they're gonna learn they're gonna be
compassionate towards us so we all have
our space space in
the universe so I was just thinking
about an actual so had discussion with
that with the e about that as well but
it's still evolving so have a nice come
up with you okay thank you very much for
joining us and I hope you enjoy coffee
[Applause]
[Music]